so look in life you get judged for a lot
of different things you do one you get
judged for your friends you have a
certain group of friends people say why
if you ain't got what people like this
you must be like X Y Z second thing we
get judged for who we date who we marry
you marry somebody people say why so he
married her that's how you process the
decision in the business world you're
gonna get judged on who you think is a
talent worth you spending time with who
you recruit who you lock onto and I can
tell you over the years I've made so
many mistakes working and locking on the
wrong person that ended up costing me
thousands of hours and I have to start
all over again
so eventually after thousands of people
have worked on I came up with ten things
I look for before deciding to lock on to
any talent all right so let's get right
into this as ten traits in people worth
developing point number one this is a
big one for me and I'm gonna explain it
to you the difference between responders
and initiators let me explain everybody
in the world is a responder everybody in
the world is a responder meaning there's
a deadline you respond you get it done
there's a task you respond you get it
done if you don't do this you're gonna
get fired you respond you get it done
taxes go up if you do this you adjust
they change the laws for something we
respond right everybody's a responder
I'm a responder your responder the
greatest leaders presidents billionaires
are all responders but only a few are
initiators I like to lock onto talent
when I see somebody initiate for example
going in there talking to a couple of
our teammates and I'll say here's what I
like to see us do I'm thinking about
doing X Y Z and one of our guys takes
the initiative because I said something
and they come back with 50 ideas that is
an initiative they took that wasn't part
of me necessarily wanting them to take
the extra mile or go above and beyond a
lot of times people will do this this is
what my tasks are I'll go up to this
point initiators will said this is what
it is let me go here if not here if not
here anybody I find that's an initiator
I like people like that on the team
that's number one look for initiators
who also respond responders don't
initiate but initiators absolutely
respond as well big difference number
two energy when it comes to energy
there's two different things of energy
to me one is your aura the other one is
your stamina let's talk about aura first
I can tell by your aura watch a person
I'll say wow look at the people at the
office that they go to lunch with look
at the people at the office they hang
out with look at the people at the
office they associate themselves with
the most look at the people that they
typically hang out with the most why is
it that this person is hanging out with
people above them why is it that this
person typically befriends people way
ahead of them
or why is it that this person befriends
people only below them that's not on
their team why is that maybe they have
an identity issue the other person is
always trying to catch up and go up
until they always want to associate
people above them like wait a minute the
aura attracts up the aura goes up this
aura goes down why is that another thing
I look at what aura is who they
typically attract so we'll have a party
will have a gather and will have any
kind of a thing I can pretty much there
every time this guy's they're the
biggest performers are always around
them every time their aura what it
projects what it attracts energy is a
complete different story I told the
story earlier to somebody about Mario
when I knew Mario was somebody I wanted
to lock on to when he was 18 19 years
old so I'm putting an event together we
have nothing prepared I only have three
four employees at that time this is 2006
we're talking a long time ago 2006 over
12 to 13 years ago and for the event
we're trying to make a video we're a day
away for the video literally a day away
from going to Palm Springs for putting
this event together for like 300 people
and we don't have the video prepared
Mario doesn't know how to edit he
learned how to edit and that night we
stayed at the office for 4:30 in the
morning never once complained he got the
job done came up we put up the video
played the video for us in 2006 this was
an epic video we created the audience
went crazy it was a great time and I was
impressed with him because I learned
about his stamina endurance he can last
I like people who can last and have
stamina people who can't lassen have
stamina and they have the long endurance
when bad things happen or a project we
got to go a little bit longer they won't
say
you know what let's not I don't know if
I can it's getting late all this other
stuff w better hanging there go long
term number three of language language
tells me a lot I can listen to personals
language and you'll typically be able to
pick up a lot the other that was doing
two interviews one guy flew in from
Connecticut the other guy flew in from
Cincinnati right and I'm sitting down
looking at these guys this is a multi
six-figure year position that I'm
looking at pretty high then at the top
of our position and as I'm talking to
one of them he made a comment two or
three times that was way too many
insecurities in these comments I said
man this is like your this is just way
too much because the position I was
gonna give him you know if I'm putting
an event together with 7,500 people he
was gonna be a face so it's gonna be
influence over 7,500 people out a live
event and listen to them like you know I
don't know about that language that
language stemmed too much insecurities
too much fears and I needed somebody for
this position to be confidence because
he or she has to impose confidence to
other people so the language you speak
will say a lot about insecurities fear
self confidence self esteem you can tell
it the language would also tell me if
there's person is a leader or their
victim while you probably would never do
this with me would you I mean why would
you ever do with me victim I think I can
do it I think this is a great position
for me let me prove you wrong watch what
I'm gonna do you know I'm gonna be one
of the best you know one time I want to
met with a talent agent in Hollywood and
I was talking to our acting and she said
listen here's what Hollywood likes they
want you to go in knowing this is my
position I'm gonna do this role better
than anybody else if you like me you
don't like me that sound you but I
believe I can play this part they want
you to go in not cocky but they want you
to go on confident knowing this was me
this is who who I think can do this job
here they like that language says a lot
about the individuals got to pay
attention to a number for parents who
believe in them I don't need both I
actually like when one parent didn't the
other day I was in a San Antonio and I'm
speaking this guy comes up to me he
walks across the stage and he comes
right past me I saw him and his girl and
I said why this guy's got swagger I said
hey come here how are you this is I'm 23
how would you growth 20 how serious are
you guys pretty serious series or like
series
Cirie's no we've been together for two
years our families know each other that
said hurt some maybe one that we're
gonna be something I said okay great I
said tell me about your parents when I
said parents his body was like shocked
he said I kind of knew you were gonna
ask that question but that's kind of you
know it's it's it's kind of tough for me
to say I said I really want to tell me
about your parents
and then he said my mom is my hero
she believes in me she thinks I can do
everything I love my mom I would take a
bullet for my mom my dad left and he's
not around and I don't have the best
relationship with my dad that's perfect
for me because one person you have to
prove wrong that I can do something big
and one person believes I want that
combination sometimes when it's both the
kid doesn't have anybody to prove wrong
so you got to find an X or a friend or a
teacher or a coach or somebody that said
I don't believe you're worth anything we
can do anything big with your life right
I want both I want somebody that didn't
believe and one that did believe but if
it's both that they don't believe we
have a problem
if a person has both mom and dad that
are very discouraging they think small
about the person you can't do anything
all that other stuff this person has to
have so much willpower to be able to
fight that part you see a lot of people
say well my mom and dad loved me and
they believed in me great that's
perfection but you see people that don't
have both you need somebody so I look in
that conversation you'll hear me say a
lot about your parents your relation
what mom and dad who are you closer to
that'll tell me a lot of confidence very
critical you give me somebody that's
very confident we can take over the
world together
number five attitude attitude to me is
believing things are possible for
instance guys that I want us to go out
there and try to do something like this
I have had I don't know if that's
possible listen I'm just telling you
this what I want to do what do you want
I want to go swim with great white
sharks yeah I just stick timing and we
have to travel in the great white sharks
no I want somebody to say let me search
your best places to swim with great
white sharks bone
let's call him up hey I want to be able
to go fly and go 100 miles an hour in
air with those you know jet type of
things I just don't know no I want to
figure out a way to make your work
attitude for
I believe we can do this let me go
figure out how we can do this and
they'll figure out a way right they find
a way they take initiative again goes
back to this but a big part of it is
attitude attitude is so attractive to me
because I know if I lock onto somebody
with positive attitude
everybody else says why does this guy
working with this person I can say look
at the attitude then they have to also
make the adjustment and respond to this
person's attitude because they initiate
the initiator improves everybody else
around them so that's point number five
number six
curiosity curiosity is very important to
me I want you to be curious so I know
your level of curiosity about the
questions you asked me so I'll sit there
with somebody we do a conference call on
a weekly basis mentor and car with about
12 people in the company and you have to
qualify to be a part of this and we'll
go an hour and a half and I'm processing
issues with them with the top 12 people
that are coming up or the top earners
whatever it is and it was this
conference called that was a number one
tiered conference call it was number
three and these people that are tier 2
or tier 3 leaders that were on the call
and the entire time for an hour and a
half the only people that asked
questions were pretty much the top five
earners on the call and then three of
the lower guys were asking questions
there was 35 people on the call I
stopped the call I say wait a minute
guys I have to chime in here they said
what I said what the hell you guys doing
on this conference call what's your
purpose of being on this conference call
you're waiting for other people to ask
questions and then hopefully they ask
the question that's on your mind to
answer that question for you but if
nobody asks that question for you you
got on a conference call that's all you
want some on conference call that you
qualified for and on this conference
call
you didn't ask any questions you should
be greedy with questions you don't get
on a conference call like this and
everybody else asked the questions this
is where you become greedy
let somebody else stop you and say
that's enough questions for you you
don't get on a conference call let
somebody else control it you control the
point of contact you ask the right
questions the people that ask the
questions are either the fastest-growing
earners in the company or they're the
top leaders and the leaders that didn't
they had a 1 spike or 2 spike and then
afterwards we're gonna see how these
people gonna respond to it but the
purpose is I know who you are based on
the questions you asked me if we sit
around each other you're not asking
questions I mean what do we
in here everything's about asking
questions right we did a video a couple
weeks ago what was it it wasn't it like
everybody is one question away from
changing their lives
Francis Bacon research without being
told how to research I like people who
are so curious that they go research how
do we do this digital marketing stuff I
spent two days researching and I want to
know about it you know how do we put an
event together I don't know idea let me
go research for three days and I
research and I gather in when I come
back with a two pager look what I got
that we just got off a conference call
right now with a guy from Netherlands
who called in he's a value tender he's
watching or writing his name is Michael
Michael if you're watching and we
literally got off the phone with you 50
minutes ago Michael's like Pat let me
tell you man I can't believe I'm on the
phone with you Michael sent a multi
multi page a report to Mario about what
to do for the bulk conference to be
better or to be incredible I've never
met Michael Michael's of iateiy no we
never asked for this we never said hey
Michael send us ideas Michael took the
initiative and he send it now I don't
know what his research is based on but
he sent it that's the point we made a
video I want to say year-and-a-half ago
I was in Miami when I shot this video at
Bal Harbour the title of the video was
how to research like an expert how to
research any topic I'm gonna put the
link over here let's put the link over
here for people to go how to research
any topic this video if you find on
right it's got like a hundred thousand
plus reviews very very specific formula
on how to research any topic click on it
go watch it if you want to get better at
researching this is a skill set I tell
you I don't know any billionaire that's
not good at researching stuff they get
the answer to the question they want all
the billionaire's I know that has tough
questions and they find the answers it's
such a common trait for them so people I
lock onto leaders are people that ask
the right questions and reconstituted
7up bringin up Rincon there's a reason
why you hear me in interviews I ask one
question I say who were you in high
school this is a question I've been
asking for 20 years let me tell you why
in high school I know who I was in high
school and I know when I ask somebody
else who they were in high school I kind
of learn about him who were you in high
school and it tells me a lot so if I
find out somebody is an athlete
why no they had to tell me about your
coach did you like your coach
well he was very tough on me okay how
did you like that the fact that he was
tough on you I don't mind it and so did
you ever have a problem with your coach
yes why because of this I mean I'm
already learning tell me tell me how
were you in high school I was a 4.7 GPA
valedictorian okay this person follows
instructions probably well right because
they're coachable so I'm learning about
them but the upbringing will tell me a
lot of different things that I can
figure out what is probably going to be
happening again if somebody says I had a
coach he was so tough on me and because
he was so tough on me every time it was
tough on me like had a conversation with
somebody three months ago and she told
me says I had a soccer coach this person
was so tough on me and when they would
be tough on me they would shut down I'm
like okay so it's a little bit more of
being on walking on eggshells because if
you challenge this person a little too
much you're gonna get shut down so you
have to be very careful how you're
speaking with this person maybe I'm not
necessarily gonna get the best out of
this person here because if you are
challenging to do something big they're
not necessarily gonna take initiative
you're gonna wait because they're more
responders right but those conversations
tell you a lot about who you're working
with number eight being able to take
criticism this is a very tough thing for
a lot of people you know sometimes you
give feedback and it depends what
department some department is you ought
to be very careful you're given
criticism with because maybe they're in
the creative department right but some
departments they're more different it's
a different role it's a different
responsibility it's a different job it's
a different type of thing they're doing
whatever it is if I'm developing
somebody to be a leader amongst a group
or to be a face or to be somebody that
I'm going to get them to maybe be an
equity owner with the company or a
position that's going to be an elite
position with a lot of upside a lot of
income a lot of future potential profit
sharing whatever maybe I am looking at
if this person can take criticism from
me when I'm giving them direction if
they can this means every time we have a
hiccup it's not going to go back down
because they shut down we have a hiccup
feedback given and then boom we have a
hiccup feedback given and then boom we
have a hiccup feedback given and then
boom right and if they're willing to
take it they're probably also going to
give it let me explain
hey pay you know what I was thinking
about the other there was that I don't
know if the system we have here is from
what is the most efficient system tell
me why see
the other day you know the way we do it
right now when we have the products that
come in and we sell an insurance policy
will we do this and what if we change
this step from here to here I love that
and the reason why you're giving us
criticism I'm the CEO if you're giving
criticism I'm the guy at the top that
means that's coming to me perfect this
is a leader I can give you criticism but
you're also giving constructive
criticism back and there's a magic on
how you do it
but both ways those that take it also
give positive back I'm not talking
complaining I'm talking about something
that's going to help the company grow
faster and become bigger and more
efficient number nine it's taking
direction being coachable listen we
announced a bonus a couple weeks ago so
1 million dollar bonus a 3 million
dollar bonus and a 6 million dollar cash
bonus do you know who are the people
that are on track to getting the highest
bonuses 6 million dollar cash bonus is
the most coachable executives in the
company why is that
coach ability from a proven mentor
speeds growth if you're not being
coachable and you question everything
you're not you know speeding increasing
speed texe winner who was a coach that
came up with the triangle offense that
Phil Jackson took and he wants six
championships with Chicago Bulls and
five with the Lakers one time they asked
Tex
they said Tex who is the one player that
knows the game is the most he says oh my
gosh there's one player coach he knew
everything about the game he says what's
the guy's name Jordan Farmar Jordan
Farmar he says yes he knows so much
about basketball you couldn't teach this
guy anything everything we ever told him
he said he knows it and he did it his
own way guess what happened to Jordan
Farmar guy came out was supposed to be a
star ended up playing in China Puerto
Rico all over the place because he
couldn't make it an M because no coach
wanted a guy like that on his team
because he questions every single thing
so he had to leave on somebody the coach
to CEO the executive wants you to long
con too
you need somebody to be able to take
direction very well increase the speed
tenfold number 10 character everything I
said sounds good but if the last ones
not in place nothing matters and by the
way character isn't just you
a church on Sunday and I read the Bible
I have character I go to service you
know whether I'm you know whatever I do
synagogue you know anywhere I go I'm so
much of a character person I'm looking
for way more than character character to
me is your health how you take care of
your body character to me is your
discipline with your finances character
to me is how you treat people around you
character to me is you keeping your word
character to me is know when you say
you're gonna do something you come
through with it character to me is you
being able to be trusted with secret
information that nobody else needs to
know about you may be the smartest
person in the world but if I give you
data that I don't want you to tell
anybody I don't even want you to tell
your wife about it or your husband about
it nothing this is secret information
here nothing that's part of character
that itself is also part of character
when I find somebody who has that and
they have these qualities we can take
over the world together very simple and
by the way if I if I wish I could have
video to show you how many times I've
screwed up in this area how many times
lost money lost time business partners
so many different mistakes so many of
them because I didn't fully look at
these kinds of formula I never looked up
and said what are the 10 traits Patrick
you look for when working with people
once we looked at this I brought it in
it increased the probability of the
results I got with the individual
because my intuition on who I worked
with became better and better and better
this is something you can get better at
when you look at it these are my 10
these 10 don't have to be your 10 you
can create your own tend to be working
with but these are Minds so by the way
you know one of the things I want to
tell you is we're growing I'm always
looking for people these are anything
anybody in anywhere if you're in the
States we're looking for CEOs right now
for the company CMOS marketers digital
marketing editors salespeople those who
know Facebook ads YouTube ads but you
gotta be an expert and you got to know
what you're doing if you're any of those
people and you're looking to want to
team up with us send me a text message
at seven four seven two six or eight
four six one once again seven four seven
two six zero eight four six one make a
two or three-minute video
send it to us with your resume we'll get
back to you we're looking for a lot of
talent right and we have so many
different companies that are growing we
need talent so send us a text again the
one video I want you to watch if you
haven't watched it go watch the video
how to research any topic I'm gonna put
the link over here again for you to
watch and if you haven't subscribed to
the channel click on the subscribe
button right here on the bottom left
take everybody bye-bye